this is the month that could define joe
biden's presidency
and american democracy for eight months
now the president's party has held a
majority in both houses of congress
and failed to get much of his
legislative agenda passed that might
change now as lawmakers return to
washington and democrats drill down on
the details in their voting rights
legislation as well as their 3.5
trillion dollar budget reconciliation
bill
and both are sorely needed on voting
rights republicans continue to push for
restrictions across the country to
relitigate the 2020 election and to
preemptively label new elections like
today's california recall and november's
virginia governor's election rigged
without any evidence twice house
democrats have passed landmark bills to
preserve and expand the franchise the
john lewis voting rights act and the for
the people act and twice those bills
stalled in the senate thanks to the
filibuster so democrats now are
advancing a new compromise bill the
freedom to vote act that bill does away
with progressive plans to expand public
financing of elections and end partisan
deadlock on the federal election
commission it also gives local election
officials a free hand to purge voter
rolls and give states more latitude to
create voter ids
hmm
it does however make election day a
federal holiday it also provides for
early voting and mail-in voting
nationwide and it includes crucial
election subversion provisions that
would make it harder for state officials
gop state officials to override election
results much of this compromising was
done at the behest of supposedly
democratic senator joe manchin of west
virginia who says he wants a voting bill
that 10 republicans will vote for in a
bipartisan manner thereby overcoming the
filibuster not all of his colleagues are
sold on that approach
senator manchin keeps reminding
everybody how the preference is always
to work on a bipartisan fashion and when
we can't that's great but
our fundamental voting rights are so
important so critical i think that if
we're not successful in getting 10
republicans to do the right thing then
we have no choice but to revisit the
rules of the senate
of course manchin strange brew of
self-interest and smarm has also
endangered the democrats signature
legislation the 3.5 trillion dollar
budget reconciliation bill that would
raise taxes on the richest americans and
spend unprecedented amounts tackling
climate change a growing priority for
progressives this summer in which one in
three americans have endured an extreme
climate-related disaster according to
the washington post in the latest such
emergency tropical storm nicholas has
brought punishing flooding to the south
just after the eastern seaboard was
racked by hurricane ida and californians
continue of course to fight wildfires
nevertheless manchin said this weekend
that the reconciliation bill's price tag
was a non-starter for him
so you're not against this you could
support this three and a half trillion
dollar plan you're not supporting
okay so that is all right now we're
getting to breath
democrats are now scurrying to come up
with even more compromises this time on
spending taxing and climate that might
placate mansion but can any climate bill
really satisfy him
this is as good a time as any to remind
viewers that manchin made his personal
fortune as a coal broker and that he
represents a big coal producing state in
the senate but you know what all we ever
hear about is the concerns of democratic
moderates quote unquote like joe manchin
and arizona senator kistan cinema who
also objects to the 3.5 trillion dollar
bill but the reality is that
progressives have as much leverage as
they do especially in the house where
nancy pelosi's majority hinges on just a
few seats and at least one of those
progressives congresswoman alexandria
ocasio-cortez has said she'll use that
leverage if the democratic party's
compromises end up looking like a
surrender
yes nothing would give me more pleasure
than to tank a billionaire dark money
fossil fuel exxon lobbyist drafted
energy infrastructure bill if they come
after our child care and climate
priorities
who better to talk to about all of this
than a founding member of the
progressive squad earlier today i spoke
with massachusetts congresswoman ayanna
pressley about the democrats tightening
window for legislation and the simmering
tensions between the parties centrists
and the progressives
congresswoman ayanna presley of
massachusetts thank you so much for
joining us on the show tonight let's
talk about one issue that this major
reconciliation bill puts front and
center climate change just yesterday you
published an op-ed in the boston globe
saying that investments in climate
infrastructure cannot wait republicans
and some of your democratic colleagues
disagree they say it's pork it's a
distraction what do you say to them
climate is infrastructure again we know
that we need to make those investments
in traditional forms of infrastructure
but you know infrastructure is more than
physical it is human as well and this is
a matter of life and death we know that
climate change is an existential threat
to our planet and certainly the most
vulnerable low-income communities of
color have been disproportionately
impacted by climate higher rates of
asthma more vulnerable to sea level rise
to extreme weather um
in equitable tree canopies my district
the massachusetts 7th congressional
district was the hardest hit in our
congressional delegation in the
commonwealth and if you line up those uh
highest
asthma rate with the highest rates of
profit infection hospitalization and
death with our heat maps they sync up
perfectly so we have got to make these
robust investments and um three things
that i'm calling for is a civilian
conservation corps um a transition to
renewable energy and a divestment from
fossil fuels so this is a
a matter of life and death and it is a
burden
bore by communities of color given
proximity to
highways toxic waste jobs to
transportation deserts food apartheid
systems unequal access to health care
again highest rates of asthma so this is
also a racial justice issue
it is indeed although one of the big
obstacles to the reconciliation bill's
passage especially the climate stuff in
it is democratic senator joe manchin of
west virginia who also just happens to
chair the senate energy and natural
resources committee how do you explain
to your voters and to climate activists
and to young people that the democratic
lawmaker writing the legislation on
climate change in the senate made his
fortune as a coal broker and enjoys the
backing of big coal and big oil how is
that not a conflict of interest
well it certainly is and i think senator
manchin owes the people of west virginia
an explanation because he is not
prioritizing
the american people
we have got to make these bold
investments 3.5 children was already a
compromise and this is simply the cost
of making up for long overdue uh
divestment and under investment in our
communities and the costs are covered
you know if we stay the course and we
tax the richest of the rich it's a
simple solution
but um you know joe manchin isn't in
charge thank god the people are and i'm
going to continue to fight for them that
we advance a bold bill with robust
investments that meets the needs of the
american people and they are urgent as
they bear the weight of these um
convergent crises a public health uh
pandemic in crisis
a pandemic induced recession and again a
national reckoning on racial injustice
so care is infrastructure housing is
infrastructure
and climate is infrastructure
another obstacle to progressive spending
uh goals is arizona senator kistan
cinema whose staff and people around her
seemed to brief axios yesterday that she
has an accountant-like focus on the
bottom line and is armed with our own
spreadsheets about the costs and tax
hikes needed for each program
i mean aside from it being a bit
patronizing
is it the case that senator cinema
understands math and the progressives
don't
well i think it's important to note that
although there is a tendency to malign
and to marginalize what are considered
progressive priorities these ideas and
these policies are actually wildly
popular and that's because they meet the
moment in order for us to
really meet the needs of the american
people we've got to make these
investments but moreover in order for us
to keep our word uh what is the point of
democrats having the house the senate
and the white house we have a majority
that was delivered to us by a diverse
coalition of multi-generational
multi-racial
issues based
activists and voters and we need to
deliver to them so they have given us
the majority uh and along with that a
mandate and being in the majority must
mean more than a talking point it is
about impact and us delivering for the
american people they don't care about
antiquated a senate process um or
washington procedures they care about
impact and that's what i'm focused on
you know the best advice i received as a
freshman three years ago was in the
process of legislating and governing
it's very easy to forget the plot and
the plot is the people and we must never
lose sight of them and i certainly make
sure i remain connected in a community
with the people that i represent so that
i'm in proximity to their hurt and i'm
not these things are not abstract for me
congressman on voting rights even though
house democrats have passed the john
lewis voting rights act and the for the
people act they've been stalled in the
senate now there's this democratic
compromise bill the freedom to vote act
that approves voter id and drops efforts
to reform the fec will you and other
house progressives accept this slim down
bill
it's the bare minimum of what we should
be doing you know certainly what you
know i would prefer is that we abolish
the filibuster and then we pass the john
lewis voting rights act and we pass the
for the people act um so this is um just
the bare minimum of what we really
should be doing i mean after all we're
talking about the disenfranchisement
of millions of voters disproportionately
voters of color
disabled voters and the elderly
progressives are also deeply concerned
about this summer's gop attack on
reproductive rights after rebuffing a
challenge uh the new texas law that
effectively bans abortion six weeks
after conception the supreme court is
now taking up a similar mississippi law
in a case that could put the final nail
in roe versus wade's coffin if there was
ever a strong case for reforming or even
expanding the supreme court isn't it now
why aren't we hearing more about court
reform from the democratic party
well because we have seen the hurt and
harm inflicted by the extremism
of the supreme court um whether you're
talking about housing rights voting
rights or reproductive freedom they have
had uh
by my vintage point contempt uh for the
most vulnerable and are uh working to
erode at uh human and civil rights that
we fought and organized a hard to earn
um and so this is not a new conversation
and in fact it is not even precedent
setting congress has the authority to do
it we've done it seven times uh
congressman mandir jones introduced a
bill of which i'm a co-sponsor um to
expand the courts and so you know what i
would like to see is that we bring to
the floor uh my bill with representative
judy chu i thank her for her leadership
all these many years i chair the
abortion rights and access task force
under the pro-choice caucus this is the
first pro-choice majority congress in
the history of congress that has to mean
something we need to bring the women's
health protection act to the floor for a
vote to codify worldview wade which is
again popular and also necessary for
reproductive freedom and would ban uh
the introduction introduction of other
harmful and draconian state laws like
what in texas
we're almost out of time but i have to
ask a question about your progressive
squad colleague alexandra ocasio-cortez
she set off a social media furore
yesterday after attending the met gala
in a designer dress with the message tax
the rich emblazoned across her back
quite the statement in a gallery full of
money elites what did you make of that
some people are saying she shouldn't
have even gone
well she has a platform and she's using
it uh both to uh steward uh discourse
and debate and to advance policy
and so our cosign tax to rich and again
for those that would argue that for all
of these bold investments that we need
to make in housing care and climate to
meet the moment in this once in a
generation opportunity once in a
lifetime opportunity to reverse
centuries of hurt to advance racial
justice um
you know we can pay for these things
there's not a deficit of resource there
is a deficit of empathy and
prioritization
so congresswoman if if
the taxing the rich part of this budget
reconciliation doesn't go far enough and
a lot of people are pointing out that
the house ways and means committee's
proposal doesn't go far enough for the
super rich will progressives like
yourself use your leverage in the same
way that mansion or cinema have in the
senate to block that
right now i'm focused on advancing these
progressive policies and the causes of
the my constituents and the american
people who are experiencing
unprecedented hurt so i'm staying at the
table i'm going to continue to fight for
this reconciliation to be as bold as
possible to meet the moment and to meet
the needs of the american people
and beyond that you know we shall see
but i don't until the ink is dry uh and
there's a vote immediately in front of
me what i'm focused on is just making
those uh making the case for why these
investments must be made it's critical
and again we have the majority and we
have a mandate and we need to act like
it
thank you so much we're out of time but
congresswoman ayanna presley appreciate
you coming on the show today
thank you